[Music]
[Applause]
man beyond I'm Kevin Smith hi I'm Marvin
oh hey we're back it's been a red-hot
minute man here we are at the scum and
villainy Cantina right here on Hollywood
Boulevard in Hollywood California throw
your hands together to the folks at home
know that your actual and real how have
you been I've been good man I haven't
seen you in a red hot minute I know I
think we both been traveling a little
bit where'd you go I went to Prince
George British Columbia oh [ __ ] I know
right you've never heard of it either
what yeah the northern fan con where we
were there last year we did it we did a
fat man up there that's right yeah he
went back they invited you not me hey
you know they're sending a pretty clear
message how was it it was it was pretty
cool it was pretty cool it's it's a
small calm it's like nine 10,000 people
up there but they're all Canadian so
they're the sweetest people in the world
they were just lovely and welcoming in
this all sounds like code for they were
all white yeah
but very nice white people yeah because
I've met some but I kept them trying to
set me up with poutine and I'm like it's
been done already guys look at me I'm
fine I'm ready to be cooked what do you
do at a con when I'm not there what is
what is the solo what's that light I
just talked to yourself
I just keep explaining why you're not
where's the other ones like well he's
he'll be here any second
what do you do I sign [ __ ] at a table I
did a writing workshop which was a ton
of fun I I did this the same thing last
year they have like a creative corner up
there and okay I want you to come up and
talk about TV writing so I had an hour
and the first year I just talked about
like here's how I got to be where I am
here's my path and here's what it's like
a little bit inside our writers room any
questions they're like no because we
live in the middle nowhere Canada and
that's not accessible to us I said okay
that's fine
but then this year I said well okay
we're gonna do this again I want to make
it actually what it's like inside a TV
writers room so we've broken episode of
TV I was like we all of us together in
this room whether it's five or fifty of
us are gonna break an episode of a
Knight Rider
right now that's pretty hot so any what
you just come up with an idea for an
episode night right yeah I was like it
like Knight Rider is a procedural the
same things have to happen every week if
I was a [ __ ] Canadian and stumbling
through this [ __ ] con and somebody
was like yo right I'm Knight Rider
I'd be like this is the best [ __ ] con
I've ever gone to way oh my god that
sounds magical how many people in the
room we started with five by the time we
ended there's about 60 people in the
room and for a convention of nine
thousand people that's like a decent
percent yeah okay but yeah because
Knight Rider a procedural is like these
things happen every week like if you
watch a Law & Order
it's alright somebody's getting murdered
right or slash sex crime they're gonna
arrest that person and then hand it over
to the lawyers and the judge and all
like there's the five or six beefs that
happen in every episode my writer he's
going to meet a pretty girl who probably
has a kid because they always do he's
going to drive kit on two wheels at
least once he's gonna jump over
something at least once there's gonna be
some bad guy who wants land rights or
whatever the [ __ ] it is there's the
scene where he drives the car onto the
truck and then backs back out and he
kisses the girl rides over in the sunset
cuz Michael Knight is not about that
[ __ ] commitment [ __ ] these things
happen in every episode so now let's
just fill in the blanks what's the bad
guy one who's the girl what's the latest
relationship between them how many kids
does she have how cute are the kids you
know like is there a demolition derby
every third episode there's a demolition
derby where there's a bunch of Hick's
you were like oh we're gonna get that
[ __ ] fancy ass future car and then
they bounce off of it all the time
because it's [ __ ] kit and just here's
how this works let's all do it together
here's act one here's act five here's
the beginning here's the end yes and we
did it in like 45 minutes and we broken
episode of TV and if I think they had a
lot of fun at least I think they did did
anyone pitch any cool ideas yeah I mean
but also it's Knight Rider so it was
never even like by the way
dragon shows up look no get the [ __ ] out
look now there's a dragon shows up burns
a chair to the ground and [ __ ] yeah like
one guy was like so how old are these
kids
why couldn't Michael Knight [ __ ] one no
that was a Canadian question yeah like
it's one of them like 19 and like kind
of hot
no I want to do the darkest episode of
the Knight Rider ever a if we're making
pretend let's do it you can't have evil
twin because that's the other thing they
they're gonna go to evil twin we don't
get to do the evil twin episode I would
have pitched in this episode Michael
takes kit to Pep Boys for a tuna so it's
just Michael Knight hanging out of Pep
Boys going like oh [ __ ] I didn't know
I wanted this air freshener as bad as I
did and buying little knickknacks and
chill and then kit just up on the
[ __ ] lift just being molested
he's got his hand in places Michael I've
never felt before
no like the people in the shop are
talking about they're gonna screw
Michael over and [ __ ] like Oh we'll tell
them it needs this and the cars like
don't lie to Michael and they're like
holy [ __ ] the car talks and then they
strike up a friendship with the car and
whatnot buy him a beer and then the car
is their new God and they begin to
worship the car like three people now
you're being [ __ ] ridiculous I'm
sorry
that's that of fun that was good yeah I
was super fun the most amazing thing
happened while I was up there though
actually on the way back from up there
so I'm on the flight back and I'm
sitting in first class because they
treat you right when they fly you to the
middle of nowhere and right behind me is
Edward James Olmos Oh [ __ ] Commander
Adama commander adama who I know Blade
Runner and Blade Runner and my hand and
deliver yes yeah totally Miami Vice as
well who I know there because he's been
on the the Battlestar Galactica at zoot
suit and zoot suit and uh deep thank you
and so he's sitting behind me and then
next to him is levar burton who was
coming from vancouver because that's
what happens in vancouver just people
end up on the flight going back to LA so
we get back to the airport and and i see
Eddie talking today now call edward
james olmos
eddie and it's super [ __ ] weird but i
do it now I don't like you really are
you on a first-name basis with Eddie
he's like good bye Mike right sir and so
he's talking to levar and and I
introduced myself to levar because we
had all kind of been in like weird
proximity and kind of having a
conversation but even though I was there
a Boulevard by the way so you know I'm
mark and I just wanted to tell you that
like when I was 14 years old
and I was watching Star Trek than X
generation I can't tell you what it
meant to me to see somebody who looked
like me in a space I wanted to be in
like at that time in my life I did not
know there was room for me in sort of
nerd media and I'm sure you get this a
lot but it means everything in the world
to get to shake your hand
anyone's like oh man that's really sweet
yeah you told me not today but I get it
that's cool watch 107 and so we're
walking through the airport like I do
that big [ __ ] speech at a terminal
and then we all have to walk together to
baggage claim and and it gets weird
because now is like I bared my soul to
you
hey there's Julia's here are you thirsty
Jordi and so we get to the baggage claim
and like his this drivers there to pick
him up and I don't get a driver because
first class yes driver no so I go to the
parking lot to get my car and I'm
staying there waiting for the elevator
again the elevator and then this arm
this like a giant kind of Ukrainian
armed like holds it open
[ __ ] wharf no also a black dude but
it was jor it was Joey's it was lavars
driver and levar comes in is like ah you
thought you get rid of Kunta Kinte that
easy not that easy [ __ ] coupe is
on you it was a [ __ ]
he's dropping [ __ ] kunta kinte and
cursed at me and that's also fairly deep
cuts referenced for levar burton oh yeah
but like he's still [ __ ] Kunta Kinte
and we'll drop a coat on yes the least
you expected yeah it was lovely and
wonderful and belated to give you a rot
now I went to my car and he went to his
chariot I guess um but it was I thought
it was like he was like oh you're not
good come on get in the car because
you're right did you so really he was
just like oh you're still here yes oh
good luck did you think this is Mark and
I influenced him nah did you think like
me and coud the kid they went like strip
clubs and [ __ ] that was next year like I
got red his rainbow we hung out all day
long now but it was very much they like
if you in the world get a chance to meet
that person he's good dude you tell you
tell that person what you feel true you
know because who the [ __ ] knows if
you're ever gonna be in that place at
that time again I give somebody in the
world means something to you tell them
go one step further man like not even
that person everybody always wear your
heart on your sleeve man nothing bad
comes from it and only good [ __ ] unless
you're a kid in school like I can see
you are you're harder sleeve they beat
you up and [ __ ] so if you're a kid
watching this never [ __ ] share your
feelings you know but when he grow up
you know [ __ ] feel everything it's
amazing I went to England and Ireland
and Scotland mmm to do some Babylon
overseas Hollywood babble-on with
Ralph's a lot of white people all nice
but very white but yes it was it was
lovely and absolutely [ __ ] a great
time but I saw Suzanne while I was there
you what a charming [ __ ] movie yeah
did you know it's fine no it's there's
there's parts of it that are super super
charming oh my god I had such a blast
I was not by myself but it was a fairly
empty screening like you know because
it's late in the run at this point but
uh you know just steeped in comic book
references and then a really like I
didn't see the the the the obvious
ending coming mm-hmm
but I was incredibly charmed by all that
yeah I thought it was I thought he was
wonderful I really liked exactly by like
he's just he's having the most fun with
the other guy wasn't it mark Strong
mm-hmm in a completely different movie
oh yeah
like in a movie where he it really is an
evil person you know I'm not just a
super villain in Shazam
I'm gonna [ __ ] murder people yeah it's
like all the people if I see you you're
dead like this is for kids it's about
family
yeah no it's about death but mr. mind it
wasn't that [ __ ] dope oh my god there
was in the beginning you saw mr. mine
who is the little caterpillar with the
talkbox around his neck and [ __ ] from
the comics so that's like one of the
first things you saw is like a behind
the shot in the Wizards cave and I was
like oh my god that's what a nice deep
cuts reference that was and then
spoilers five four three two one
he [ __ ] shows up at the end of the
movie as well and I was like this is the
most Medal movie I've ever seen in my
[ __ ] life oh I loved it I loved it so
much I had a good time watching that I
am so happy no I did not I'm not gonna
[ __ ] on it too much my one problem I
think we talked about it is that the boy
who plays Billy Batson yeah does not
seem to be the same man who's played by
Zach Levi whereas if you watch big you
have no problem believing that Tom Max
is playing a ten-year-old right and the
same ten-year-old but in this movie it's
like oh you were kind of like a southern
sullen withdrawn [ __ ] teenage emo kid
and now you're a dick
who really likes having a good time he
turns his like weird frat superhero
broke-dick like that's not the same kid
I think that was the working title
superhero frat bro dick and they're like
let's just go she's saying yeah
like it didn't test that well what else
did I do while I was over there other
than go to shows when I was in
Manchester I had like three days where I
was in Manchester and like we had great
weather over there so I got to go out
shopping what a great city man like they
had this building called a flex palace
which is just kind of like three stories
of an indoor flea market and like I love
going to flea markets it was making
money these days yeah I opened a flea
market
Martha's it was ironic I was just I was
sitting there talking to people because
some people like hey it's [ __ ] you
and so some people were like a flex
palace right right and I was like yeah
yeah and then I was like I live in a
flex palace and they look at me funny
and I was like I bought his house like
almost 20 years ago
and they're like and they moved on and
[ __ ] but what a great day I had walking
around just like shop and I bought a lot
of [ __ ] like local art and stuff like
that I realized that like that's what
I'm drawn to if you draw something and
hang it up and put a price tag on it
like I'm your [ __ ] I'm your so you're
mark like I'll walk right up and be like
oh my god I have to have that drunk
about a drawing of a [ __ ]
stormtrooper crying that's he was on the
phone and he goes those were the droids
were looking for my wife was like why
what are you gonna do with that I was
like I don't know but I have to support
that it exists so [ __ ] nice noted
all right draw thing [ __ ] sign it
charge of mint for it and I got you you
do so the mark and then other than that
I've just put him post on the movie man
we're down to 94 minutes she's really
tight [ __ ] tight as a drum running
time today we did music all day to kind
of shore up this soundtrack and the
score it's awesome I've been showing it
now
to folks at any time you want to come
over and watch you just let me know I
mean I've seen it though did you see the
thing yeah we did that at all that's
right yeah
no weird I was reinventing you we did
this
yeah it's that's kind of the modem in
right now is like come watch the flick
yeah and I was like when you were
watching it was helpful because then I
was still looking for cut no it's mmm
but now there's nothing to cut and so we
just have screenings and it's like
satisfying for me but like it's not
productive but every once in a while
like one ends and somebody tries to give
me notes and [ __ ] and I'm like no we're
done shut up keep it to yourself yeah
like you hold that to the next movie but
I dug it I dug it and I told you that oh
thank you yeah I wasn't even looking for
that yeah you did I was like it's it's
it's sweeter than it is funny and it's
very funny
yeah it's try to put that on the poster
there you go tell yours I can I can put
a price tag on it do then I'm a mom I
think that's all I got for open I can't
think of anything ever if anything
beyond that no I know we got news and I
just want to dive into Game of Thrones
shall we start them we should [ __ ] do
that then alright folks man the show is
divided into two halves and the first
half is generally us relying on Marx
origins as a new sound as a newsmen as
somebody who worked for the news and
edited a bunch of news and [ __ ] to dig
up the news for us so we turn to mark
and Mark turn to the Internet and so
mark brought us news give it up for mark
with the news
[Applause]
so uh so yeah Game of Thrones less news
and more use a [ __ ] thing that I watched
I'm sorry that came out more negative
than I thought yeah that I watched was
gonna I don't know though you sound like
the internet like everybody seems rather
I haven't yet to see anybody go like
completely satisfied the end game good
and I think that was the problem right
it's like we just saw somebody stick the
landing insanely well with the ending of
a series granted it was a cinematic
series but you know 22 [ __ ] single
entries and then a big old [ __ ]
wrap-up and [ __ ] we spent about the same
amount of time with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as we did Game of Thrones and
you know the cats who were telling a
game of Thrones story we're doing a
really [ __ ] great job and [ __ ] and so
I just think everyone's a little
flabbergasted that it's it's it's come
to an end and it wasn't when anyone
wanted that what we're looking for yeah
I mean it's uh I was talking to somebody
today and I was like the thing to
realize is that Frank Sinatra never
wrote a song that was not his gift his
gift was interpreting songs his gift was
I will take these words that are on a
page and I will make them the best
version of this song you've ever seen
but I do not have the gift of inventing
I can't put one note after another and
say no that's how that should go and
then followed with another 500 notes
just not my thing
I feel like when this show had the song
already written for it it [ __ ] sword
like once it was no we know exactly what
to do we can choose what to leave out we
can interpret this text the way we want
to but then they went they had no more
book all they had and the and the things
about the books was not the plot it was
here's how these characters work
together how's that here's how we weave
this insanely intricate character story
so that by the time you get to a thing
like the red wedding it's gonna hit you
like a [ __ ] ton of bricks and the
plot is almost not like the red wedding
comes at the end of a season where
Catelyn Stark is negotiating to cross a
[ __ ] bridge we spent a year crossing
a bridge and the end of that is oh well
the only way to do
this is for you my son to pledge himself
to your daughter and then that'll be
cool and then he'll be a [ __ ] stark
man and never do what you're supposed to
do and then it's gonna go badly and Oh
everybody has to die now but the taking
that time to build all of those
character pressure points yields
something that amazing and by the time
they didn't have the character roadmap
what they had was a plot road map where
that was george RR martin sitting down
with Benioff and Weiss and saying here's
what happens and I'm like cool we got it
we can stitch together this this this
road map and get you where you said you
wanted to end right but without any of
that character underpinning it all just
felt like I mean yeah I could see how
Danny goes nuts you've established that
she was gonna go nuts
but the minute of her full-on nuts going
doesn't feel like you told me that story
you know it's never like oh I fully
understand why she decided to burn
King's Landing it was like well no she
killed MELAS under the Lassonde the last
episode and here Jorah died the episode
before so yeah the math checks out but
it's not about math it's not about plot
it's about I feel the way she's feeling
and I understand why she has to do a
horrible thing aside from oh yeah I know
we wanted to be bad like and we'll tell
you she's bad because of this awesome
[ __ ] dragon wing shot behind her
we're just like have you got it yet flap
flap just in case you missed
I like the shot I thought it was cool
but a lot of people on the internet were
like oh my god this is how you [ __ ]
visually tell a story and I'm like yeah
I guess for all the people who are like
who's the bad guy yeah this is my first
episode whose new look I just came in at
the end tell me what this is about
I am this is my take away and I agree
with you I think to some degree like it
clearly felt like they ran out of road
map and they were like [ __ ] it will tell
the story ourselves and at a certain
point you were like go back to what the
guy was doing that was good but not so
much that as I think they should have
done six and six
think they should have done six episodes
of the night King battle and you know
[ __ ] battle of Westeros whatever
they're calling it and should know
Battle of Winterfell six episodes tying
up that storyline and then go off the
air for [ __ ] year again if they have
to and then six episodes of just Danny
goes nuts and what do we do and and the
battle for the iron throne and [ __ ]
sorry I'm coming I'm coming off of a
some [ __ ] thing off to traveling like
just call their head cold it just felt
very rushed like I don't I you know I've
watched the show so I saw the signs and
like she was always talking about I'm
gonna take that [ __ ] throne and fire
blood and you're like alright she's you
know god she's a Targaryen but like it
just felt like the last two episodes
like things were going fairly gracefully
and then they were like hurry to [ __ ] up
and yeah it was like life is a weird
metaphor but like is it it was like
having amazing sex and then suddenly
like oh [ __ ] my parents are home and oh
[ __ ] and and so like you know most of it
is memorable and [ __ ] cool and [ __ ]
but the end really just [ __ ] went
weird and I think I came I'm not sure
still you know apropos of almost nothing
I learned the most amazing term in the
writers room last week okay have you
heard of a danger wank danger danger
wank danger wank no it is lotion tissue
box pants around your ankles porn mom so
you trying to beat mom into the road Wow
[Music]
I uh
danger wank I liked my mom too much to
do this not gonna like that and we
played that game without me even
intending to so Tiger what oh [ __ ]
you're back give me two seconds but yeah
it's it's I'm trying to find a track to
get back onto but yeah it's just that
that you wanted these character stories
that you've been invested in for eight
nine years what are you missing water
can I get a couple bottles of water
please
good like for the entire show Aria has
been like here's my [ __ ] list I'm
going to kill all the people on this
list and I'm gonna be made whole and if
you like yeah [ __ ] it okay she's going
for it yeah [ __ ] wall - phrase on the
list
Livan get night king is on the list I'm
gonna knock these [ __ ] off and let's
keep on moving and then in like 10
minutes the Hound is like you know what
maybe you don't want to be this why
would I not want to be this this is what
I've been about what do you have to be
don't be like me like no I'm gonna get
my revenge you never got your revenge
that's why you're [ __ ] up I kill the
people on my list [ __ ] so I'm gonna go
get Cersei because that's the last name
on my list and the fact that she doesn't
is like what yeah I found the death of
Cersei and Jaime really unsatisfying
yeah I was kind of hoping that like they
kill each other or [ __ ] you know she
already comes in and kills her at least
cuz we were promised green eyes you know
so would see like it's either gonna be
Cersei or it's gonna be Daenerys and it
was neither yeah it was look at me I can
injure my way around this city and see a
bunch of awful things and remind you Jon
Snow what you're supposed to do here I
mean yeah and then there's that weird
like 10 minutes scene with the horse
you know where you're like well this is
the mean this is like everyone started
signing meaning to it online they're
like [ __ ] she is death and on a pale
horse she's gonna ride and she's gonna
be the one who kills Danny and nothing
like she got on the horse and [ __ ]
took off at the end of that episode and
then the next episode when [ __ ] they
spent twenty minutes to Tyrion looking
around going wow she really did burn
everything didn't she
all Zen [ __ ] Arya is back on hey I
didn't go for her she did a lap just
like yes yeah that too was weird I had
this weird sensation and it was actually
good to watch because like it made me
kind of go back into my movie and edit
do one more pass with this ear I did you
watch it like this I watched both
episodes going like these are the last
two hours of this show ever what the
[ __ ] is this about and so like when you
know we saw the in the second tool at
the penultimate episode her scorching
[ __ ] King's Landing and [ __ ] like
that
you know I and we were on the ground
watching [ __ ] like it just gets
roasted I felt like that was that's
that's great Lana you can't do better
than that I felt like I was there and
then the first 10 minutes in the next
episode they let Tyrion walk around and
look at it and I understand like if we
had two more seasons to go take your
time let him take it in but it's like
we've already seen this [ __ ] like are
you seriously gonna waste 10 minutes of
the last episode of Game of Thrones
letting this guy walk around and go like
she sure killed a lot of people you know
and then I'm like alright so [ __ ] we
didn't see Jamie and and Cersei get
killed so maybe we're gonna see him in
this last episode because if Tyrion is
going downstairs maybe he's gonna find
out they're not there and there's gonna
be a scene adopt their [ __ ] dad like
and everything like and they let they
let him go find him and look at him and
they got crushed by a ceiling yet their
heads are not crushed and they look
pretty as fog and then he weeps and
there's no like it was just to me that
felt like [ __ ] man like you only got I
kept looking at the clock oh and you
only got 45 minutes left to the the rest
of Game of Thrones and you're gonna do
this so I did that
and it made me go back into James Aubrey
boot and go alright view it through that
prison like some angry fan that's like
you made me wait 20 [ __ ] years for a
sequel this is in the movie and [ __ ] so
I went out and cut out anything remotely
[ __ ] extraneous so that like I get
standby every single word spoke and go
like yeah man I'm [ __ ] that made it
through that all the way and here's why
I could justify it I don't know that you
could justify I mean you don't have to
it's [ __ ] art right but like I sat
there watching it going like this is a
lot of waste of time man like you could
be telling more story you could be doing
some cool [ __ ] as opposed just having a
guy look around and some people be like
nah but he needs to see that in order to
make the turn so we could throw his
[ __ ] pin on the ground and [ __ ] like
that but he saw it yeah he was just
outside the city going all [ __ ]
everything's on fire yeah the brawl was
right [ __ ] like it was just I don't know
those are the things and I'm not saying
I would have done better or [ __ ] this
is what I would have done I was just
surprised they'd that kind of did some
of the things they did yeah
well here's what I would have done I
kept on feeling the entire last season
this entire run like the conclusion but
again it's about moments and it's about
feeling and it's like it seems as if so
much of this show has been about look
how awful it is to have a [ __ ] Iron
Throne
look how how much chaos it's caused to
have a king or a queen and rest on this
iron throne mm-hmm
destroy the throne right like okay cool
who's gonna do it well probably Jon Snow
if he's not a [ __ ] he's gonna kill
Danny and then have Gendry cut it up
into seven pieces and give a sword to
each member of a kingdom and it's seven
kingdoms again right just [ __ ] do
that it's easy
we don't need absolute power corrupts
absolutely nobody has absolute power
we're a Council of Kings did they do
that in the books or something I don't
know I never in the books but but I'm
like alright cool
so who destroys the throne a dragon why
unclear alright fine
I guess the dragon doesn't like metal
stabby things so melt this chair because
I hate chairs and then it's okay so we
need a new king why
why do you need a new king like
shouldn't if you're gonna listen to
Tyrion again Wireless Ana Tyrion unclear
because he's like if that scene begins a
great where I'm going you don't say
anything else he's like I won't but hold
on and then gives a [ __ ] speech for
the like the little guys right let's
elect a new king and you're like what
the [ __ ] happened I thought he was about
to be put to death yeah and I was like
you know II have a new king it's like
why do we need a new king why it's
somebody explain to me why this has been
a good thing for anyone yeah and I'll
tell you what in a world where they're
picking kings and [ __ ] last choice brand
like I mean not because I'm like oh he's
[ __ ] useless I don't like his acting
or anything big doesn't work yeah where
the sots of reason was so strange man
could you imagine like everyone's like
we want you to be king and your sisters
like he's [ __ ] [ __ ] you know he's
like well technically that's not true
man I got the dick of a three-eyed Raven
I can see a future
I just don't her cigs I remember that
boy specifically saying I can't be Lord
of anything I'm the three-eyed Raven and
then he's like but you didn't say King
and so now he's [ __ ] king and also
like if the metric for choosing the king
is who's got the best story bran wasn't
even in all of this [ __ ] story he
vanishes in like season 4 like what are
you doing being dragged around the
[ __ ] woods for a while by this lady
who we've never mentioned again she
lived how about your [ __ ] bad-ass
sisters like one of which use an
eleven-year-old who watch your head
their dad's head get cut off and travels
the [ __ ] realms and becomes the most
feared assassin in the world that's a
good story
what about your other sister who's been
like brutalized by a bunch of dudes
which the show takes a little bit too
much relish in but whatever who like
overcomes like vast and awful spousal
abuse to become the queen of winter like
she's got a [ __ ] great story honestly
felt like we were being set up for you
know the old King Conan story like
essentially Jon Snow is like oh it's
mine but I don't want it [ __ ] yes but
the idea is like well it's yours and
whether
you want her not heavy is the head that
wears the crown so in a world where he
Isis Daenerys I fully expected he's like
gonna be the sad king who ruled wisely
but [ __ ] he was emo he's the king
Morrissey and [ __ ] like that but but
then all of a sudden he goes to jail
again
Condon or and they dropped the entire oh
you're the last Targaryen you have the
the right to [ __ ] rule be like
alright John you're the [ __ ] king we
don't give a [ __ ] that you killed the
Queen because your claim to the throne
was better so bully on you what do you
want to do I want to abolish the Iron
Throne and all Kings I'm gonna go live
in the [ __ ] North peace out y'all
like let him do it let him break the
wheel which isn't who's got a dick and
he can have children it's this [ __ ]
awful system of government like break
the wheel but I didn't do that so yeah
and Howard Brown that was her thing she
wanted to break the wheel yeah I was
Danny's thing and that whole thing was
that we gotta [ __ ] break the wheel of
slavery and tyranny and like everybody
in slavers Bay like my whole [ __ ]
campaign speech was I'm gonna break the
[ __ ] wheel yeah well I mean at the
end of the day the whole thing was
pretty good for the stark family like
when you consider the show begins with
the stark family and then ends with the
stark family in the beginning it starts
with like the oh [ __ ] they killed our
dad and called him a traitor and blah
blah blah and now one of them's queen in
the north and one of them is Dora the
Explorer and one of them is one of them
[ __ ] the king I had three-eyed Raven
yeah this dark and one of them is you
know the king-beyond-the-wall if he
wants to be that was the other thing
like gray worms like he's got to go to
jail forever and like we're gonna send
him to the [ __ ] wall again and [ __ ]
first off I'm like did you see that shot
of the repaired wall [ __ ] you like who
did that like they were all off fighting
the [ __ ] King of the night and [ __ ]
you mean they left behind a regiment to
be like you guys fix this [ __ ] wall
well who you [ __ ] me an ice dragon
[ __ ] blew it apart and [ __ ] oh I got
I don't care a few pipes will do it and
that's what they did they showed this
one shot where it's like come on but
once you prepare the wall who you
[ __ ]
there's no more Walker that's it it's
like once they [ __ ] done with the king
of the night and [ __ ] it's like take the
whole [ __ ] wall down man like that I
didn't understand and then they send him
back there and it's you know you're
gonna be a [ __ ] now you're gonna take
the oath or the black and live at Castle
black you know the same way the show was
beginning but then they have a shot
where he just [ __ ] off from Castle
black and he's like was grey worm gone
[ __ ] it listen though and then just goes
into the deep woods and [ __ ] so yeah
what's that meant to be does he become
the king of the [ __ ] way north or
super north and is he no longer like in
Castle black or what do they call that
[ __ ] your bro when they yeah I mean he
he starts a brewery in the in the far
far north and that's it that's his story
I was gonna ask did you read the books
you said you didn't read it
yeah I don't know it just seems like we
were being told a different story and at
the very end they're like PBS this has
always been about bran and you're like
what yeah but you just want the moments
right like the thing you take away from
a finale of the show is the moments with
the characters that you've written with
that seemed to at the very least if not
validate your decision to ride at least
haven't made it a little bit worthwhile
right like after Bryn's weird [ __ ]
pining over Jamie and she gets to go
write his story in the [ __ ] the the
annals of the leaders of the Kingsguard
right turn the [ __ ] page sir Brienne
of Tarth like you know first of her name
is the new [ __ ] leader of the
Kingsguard yeah also who may be pregnant
with Jamie's child
but just like something to righta that
would've been cool to why they
recognized the years of her service and
where the the depth of her story and the
here's a little bit of throw forward
going on like there is one more
lannister in the world or at least
through some shits throw some shade on
the pages like had a small dick had a
golden dick yeah i i'm certainly not
complaining in terms of like you know
this is what they should have done or
anything like that i you know still they
were [ __ ] that i liked I liked her
[ __ ] speech when she was like now
we're going to Winterfell I was like
[ __ ] y'all watch that show like go go
fight to go do the same [ __ ] you did
here they're like start wars everywhere
because ultimately I mean where do you
stand on her roasting people I mean I
think that if if the scene that you had
gotten was the bells are ringing she's
she's battered through the walls all the
scorpions are down and her armies are on
the field and she's perched overlooking
King's Landing and she's about to
[ __ ] like alright it's cool I got it
it's done and one of those soldiers
kills grey worm like one of those
soldiers one of the Lannister army men
like everyone else is surrendering and
one [ __ ] dude kills the last
attachment she has to the world I buy
that as a trigger to like I was on the
edge like it was keeping it in check
yeah and that happens [ __ ] everybody i
buy that like it's you know it's the
it's the pulp fiction like he killed the
kind of a foot massage extreme what i
understand it you know like no no it's
an overreaction
but the validity of the reaction is
there right but just heard like I'm
crazy now is the least interesting
version of what that character is I
didn't I didn't mind it so much I wasn't
like you know all this is complete
betrayal of the character and all this I
mean and maybe that says something about
my personality but I was like [ __ ]
good they're all pricks like you know
they kill their children
well I am you know that's the thing like
they went to such pains to show you like
the corpses of children like well yeah
it didn't shoot down a dragon true yeah
I guess there's that I don't know it's
been a fickle [ __ ] City right like
one minute like [ __ ] Cersei shame
shame and then they like protect us
Cersei so I that's why she I felt like
indifference to them I thought it was
kind of hot though when she was at the
window and [ __ ] Daenerys is like just
smoking fools and like for the first
time ever sir she's like oh no like you
know she didn't see this coming she was
like oh let's see her [ __ ] kill women
and children to get to me the breaker of
chains and she's like oh [ __ ] she's
doing it that would have been more
satisfying it's like at one point they
showed the dragon the drill gun or
whatever with Daenerys I was like come
and it looked like she was coming at
Cersei but never did yeah yeah do that
like more so than like roast everybody
else I do think though that the winner
of the game of Thrones is Lena Headey
who managed to get a million dollars for
every episode of the last two seasons
where all she did was sit at a window
and drink wine do I got to do anything
no look Imperius get off some clothes
and just sip wine great cash the [ __ ]
check yeah really and she I think she
had in this final-season about 12 lines
total mm-hmm nice work if you can get it
yeah what what is your favorite if you
can think of it series finale
I mean it's not my favorite but it Raviv
just finished and I thought they
finished very well mmm like it's stuck
there Landing incredibly well there was
a beat in it where I was like no but in
retrospect it that too was very on point
on brand and in character for what they
did so they they ended really well you
know Seinfeld I remember being like what
but not like angry or anything what's my
favorite it's not my favorite but I
remember they ended facts of life well
we've learned all the facts I am I'm
very partial to angel the angel season
finale
damn what did angel do to you because it
ends like the the entire last season was
also bit abbreviated they were supposed
to have a 22-episode run they ended up
with 10 and they did accelerate the
storytelling but it ends with angel and
like his two buddies cohorts you know
soldiers their arms standing in an
alleyway it's raining and there's a
[ __ ] dragon coming down the alley and
there's an army of demons on one side
and an army of something else on the
other side and it's literally just all
right you take the army in the left you
take the home and they right I'm gonna
take the dragon and it's it ends with
them in battle like it's this is a
character who this is all he does is he
fights the fights that need fighting and
so ending with him
in the middle of engaging in a fight he
can't possibly win felt appropriate to
what that character was in that story
that he was like he's a hero and this is
what heroes do like I bought that and it
ended in such a way that no I feel
excuse me what the character feels I
feel what he's supposed to be feeling in
this moment that's what I want it's
emotional resolution I could give a [ __ ]
about plot resolution I don't care that
much about the 98 plots that they left
hanging in Game of Thrones like I just
want to feel as if these characters are
where their story should have taken them
Battlestar Galactica had a good ending
yeah except for angels that was the
whole season thing yeah it was just they
decided it was going to be divine and
I'm like oh sure because angels the
Starbuck thing there's no but yeah that
was always this little tough to explain
but the final episode I thought was yeah
because it gives you it's it is an
episode of Battlestar Galactica that
gives you the things you've come to
expect from an episode of Battlestar
Galactica the giant [ __ ] space fights
weird philosophical musings a crazy-ass
flash-forward and a cameo from the
Creator alright
cool I'll take it the who's the cameo
from creator the very last scene is of
six and Baltar walking down a street in
midtown Manhattan and they passed by a
newsstand and Ronald Moore is reading a
newspaper at that newsstand yeah I
forgot about that
spoilers I'm sorry did I [ __ ] up battle
straw for anybody it's not the series
finale but this I just watched both
flash had a really good season finale
did you see that
they did a season of him and his kid
know him in an iris and their kid from
the future he was like a villain right
no no she was it was all about how she
was I'm gonna cry just thinking about it
it was all about her trying to you like
be a a hero oh my god that [ __ ] really
does it for me it was it was really well
done and bittersweet because they
couldn't you know keep the the the
character I don't wanna spoil it but it
was incredibly [ __ ] well done
heartbreaking and then Supergirl just
finished up last week and Jon Cryer was
Lex Luthor fantastic yeah yeah like I
with all due respect to Gene Hackman he
may be the best live-action Lex Luthor
we've ever had closest to the guy in the
comics somewhere Michael rosenbloom is
just like [ __ ] you had a lot more time
to play the character but Cryer really
[ __ ] embodied like the bad Lex Luthor
the the adult evil Lex Luthor is good
man they just good [ __ ] with their
storyline but you know it's easy to
finish it not easy but easier to finish
this season right than it is to finish
the series yeah because they're like hey
man if you don't like it there's another
season on its way but with fighting
something like Game of Thrones it's like
this is it if you don't like it you're
[ __ ] forever yes until the prequel is
that what's next yeah they're shooting
the pilot for the prequel which I think
takes place thousands of
years before this June oh that'll be
satisfying here's my here's my question
there's something has been rolling
around the internet and I don't know how
people would know this but they were
like this could have been a longer
[ __ ] season and but these guys the
writers wanted to go off and do [ __ ]
star wars and that's why this season is
truncated as it is have you read that is
that true is why why are people saying
that how do they know that it is true
that Benioff and wives are doing Star
Wars they're doing Star Wars and it's
true that Benioff and whites were the
ones who decided to end it where they
did and how they did with his HBO would
have done nine more seasons of this they
would have been happy to [ __ ] have it
but Benny - why so like now I think this
is the end of our story this is this is
the end of our road and HBO was like
okay with that and they can't do that
show without them at last point the
actors I think would have revolted I
think the actors were the yeah man
everyone's loyal until they're like and
then the like Benny often what well I
mean like I think that one of the big
reasons that that I just stopped at the
bank before I guess my wife has me pick
up a bunch of money one of the reasons
why my gun comes back for guardians
three is because that cash stood with
him dave bautista special he was like
I'm not coming back if it's not for him
so we saw Donna was like I'm not coming
back I'm not for him that's not true
they didn't say that Dave Bautista came
closest but none of them said all of
them were like we love James and we
stand behind him and that's all we'll
say nobody said I ain't coming back if
you don't come back I let you know
something nobody else does I believe
that part of that negotiation part of
that like sort of year-long distance
between him getting fired him coming
back was them realizing [ __ ] we might
get one we might get two we might get
the once with a broker but there's some
of these were just not getting back I
admire your childlike innocence
Dewey Dewey with wonder huh who knows I
wasn't in the room so I don't [ __ ]
know but if I had to guess no way but it
never got there anyways never got there
good well Matt I think it's it's
pressure that helps yeah I think that
you know HBO is like yeah these
[ __ ] won a dozen Emmys for us
and they delivered the biggest show
we've ever had if they want to go out if
they're not if they wouldn't be happy
doing this show anymore no matter how
much we pay them then all right hire
someone else you know what I'm saying
like I'm sure george RR martin would've
been like i'll take over maybe we would
stop him from writing the book I find
that strange
I find it strange man that they were
like well the writers don't want to go
on so [ __ ] it we won't go on when it's
such a cash cow like I'm curious how
many people drop to HBO or cut the cord
like the night after the day it was done
that is why they they rushed to get a
[ __ ] Westworld trailer in front of it
and ended it with a watchman trailer be
like we got on the show we swear you're
gonna love us we still love you nerds
like Game of Thrones how about this [ __ ]
yeah how about a little peek into a show
you won't get for 18 [ __ ] months what
shows that Westworld
but 2020 that shows not coming back into
big eight they had the temerity to show
a trailer for a show then coming on for
like yeah might as well be [ __ ] put up
a trailer for like the end of the world
and be like one day just keep
subscribing yeah soon they do have a
pretty strong lineup though as I was
watching like because they did in and
day at the top and bottom of every piece
of programming for the last month with
like there's other [ __ ] they're there
they'll be fine like you know I don't
know they're gonna be fine as they were
with Game of Thrones but HBO has always
had a bunch of interesting stuff
although like they're that [ __ ] do
you see was the the Polar Bear show
they're doing His Dark Materials is that
like didn't do we there was a movie yes
wonderful some [ __ ] polar bear movie
with Nicole Kidman and James Bond
yeah that's the same [ __ ] same [ __ ] is
this every boot of that or are they all
in like went back to the source material
and readapted it
but we're not supposed to think about
the the jo4 oh my god you don't think
about that original all right so like I
was sitting there going like Jesus how
many of these [ __ ] polar bear stories
did they got out there but apparently
it's the same [ __ ] same one do you
think that does any business I think it
does why I know that stuff I don't very
well but I remember those books were
huge when they first came out like they
were still adolygiad following for it
and I think fantasy if you do it at a
high level and you execute it well
there's always gonna be an audience for
it right and if there's an underpinning
of a book beneath it then not to say
that that's the only reason you would
watch it but I see them rolling the dice
for it okay there's an audience who
knows this [ __ ] who likes this [ __ ] and
didn't like the last adaptation of it
let's give them the thing they've always
wanted and hope that other people like
this is interesting okay cool that's
what I was with [ __ ] Game of Thrones
was like I'd never read the books true
but oh [ __ ] I like dragons and swords
and magic and boobs why would I not
watch this I believe that was the
working title dragons and swords and
magic and Moon I have I have the poster
Revenge of the Jedi poster that's good
alright what else we got I went to the
movies I I saw Jon week three I did I
mean I enjoyed John wick a lot
especially because it's predicated on
like you know I'm gonna kill all these
[ __ ] because they hurt my dog and if
I remember correctly spoilers they did
more than hurt the dog didn't make they
did yes there's blood on the tile does
he get another dog at the end of that
movie yes he does right I mean again I'm
like I'm not the world's biggest fan but
I remember enjoying the [ __ ] out of that
movie and being like who [ __ ] knew a
movie with a born ass name like John
wick could be this [ __ ] good like you
know what a simple package but my god
but not enough for me to see John wick
too that happened already right it
happened already and I wasn't against it
I just never caught up to it yeah I mean
i-i've seen them all they kill his dog
again they did not kill his dog again
this time they killed this cat he's a
god damn Addison gave me that guinea pig
you sons of [ __ ]
why do you keep killing my pets how was
this this this one was the best action
movie I had ever seen for the first 45
minutes ooh
divert the first one on a poster are
amazing they're phenomenal I mean it's
it has all of like the precision and
inventiveness and humor and playfulness
of a great Jackie Chan movie ooh and
like those like mid-period Jackie Chan
is the best action that's ever been okay
but then what happens is it's still that
for the rest of the movie which is it's
a movie that teaches you how to be
desensitized to it while watching it you
know like is if you see John Waite get
thrown through the 98th [ __ ] glass
door you're like all right I guess like
yeah get back up punch another dude sure
get more bullets let's shoot 58 more
guys but the first movie works because
it's a revenge thriller because it's you
killed my dog the dog was the avatar for
my love of my wife and my wife sent me
this dog as her last living Act on earth
to teach me to love again and you killed
the thing that I was supposed to teach
me to love again and free that everybody
[ __ ] dies this is a great way to
[ __ ] describe John wick yeah you know
talkative as hell and like but once he
completes that circle like and the
second movie it's like I got to get my
car back
because my car had the last picture
picture of my wife in the glove
compartment and so I got to get that
[ __ ] picture was that the plot of two
that's that's but it also gets the car
in the first 10 minutes and then it's
like then it's I can't get back out like
once I walked into this world again they
won't let me leave right he's got a
marker it becomes a whole like I have
the turn in sand like fancy time dude
and really thin suits like I have this
marker for you you have to come back to
work for me it's like I don't wanna you
have no choice John Wiig and so he
[ __ ] does it and kills five hundo
don't you understand they killed my dog
and I dealt with that I just want to
heal again and not heal like a dog would
heal
because that hurts right and so the end
of the second movie it's John wick does
the unthinkable which is he kills a dude
on the Continental Grounds in that hotel
that's run by Ian McShane who again well
watching anything there's no you weren't
allowed to kill people there the
Continental is sacrosanct is they did
for the first two movies nobody got
killed there nobody got killed there's a
whole [ __ ] well doctor one guy gets
killed there and the lady who gets
killed becomes the target of every other
[ __ ] assassin in New York because she
broke the rules of the Continental she's
now excommunicate Oh which is like fancy
Italian for everybody [ __ ] to kill
that person and and so that's what
happens at the end of the second movie
he kills the dude who brings him the
marker the fancy Italian dude who's like
I'm never going to let you go John week
you're going to do everything I ever
needed you to do including like iron my
[ __ ] shirts and then kill the person
who made me the shirts and so he kills
that guy and then it's John wick is
excommunicate Oh
price on his head is fourteen million
dollars and now the entire world wants
to kill John wick the third movie is can
I make them stop killing me who do I
have to talk to you about that and then
it's like I'm gonna take a plane to
Casablanca or fence or someplace like
kind of vaguely euro Middle Eastern and
talk to the world's first assassin who
will say you have to cut off your finger
and rededicate your than a blah blah
blah blah like there's no more who
played the world's first assassin Sayid
Tajima GUI I think I've heard that name
I'm sure it sounded like a good thing
for like Nic Cage to do hey you know
like Nic Cage versus Keanu Reeves would
be a good scene right be like a
modern-day De Niro Pacino heat thing Oh
that'd be great yeah have they ever
worked together before Keanu Reeves in
the case they haven't
I think we got a can a sale on our hatch
let's go over there and say those two
names and have people be like you're
right we don't even need to tell them
guys we sold a movie with you in it what
do we do
we'll get them no let's say what this
movie is missing is that emotional that
pure simple emotional pull of they
killed the totem of my wife and now
everybody needs to die without that it's
just violence and it's artful violence
it's like the best executed violence
you've ever seen but it becomes like a
music video by the end of it and you're
like it doesn't mean anything to me it's
cool to look at but any often why said
that I'm one of those after Game of
Thrones things I guess the well maybe it
was the Battle of Winterfell episode or
whatever but they were just like can't
just fight for like an hour it gets
boring and [ __ ] and at first I was like
[ __ ] you you're wrong but then I was
like now they're right like they would
get ya like a boy you gotta stop to
breathe and have a character moment
otherwise that you just kind of get
desensitized sounds like you got inured
by I know but and so do the audience
like the audience I saw it on like
opening night and like the first 40
minutes there's applause like there's
hooting and hollering there's like we
are here for a [ __ ] good time
am I the end of the movie after like the
fourth boss fight everybody's just kind
of quiet and another dog just got it
done we got a reinvest so yeah like I I
I loved Keanu Reeves in those movies I
like those movies I just feel like they
need to find that other reason for me to
care about those movies they're fine and
quick they announced they're making a
four or hell yeah and it D throned
Avengers did it really it did it made
like fifty two million dollars domestic
which was enough and them and Avengers
made how much so far 2.6 billion
worldwide yeah so John wick really did
throned Avengers they did yeah I saw
them just for a fourth time did you
really I did and and I don't say that in
a way of like how could you what's your
[ __ ] problem when did you find the
time
I just carved out three hours that I
didn't need for anything else
did that when I was overseas but instead
I went to see Shazam I literally went to
go see Avengers and then I saw that she
Sam was playing I was like you know I
should I have I've seen Avengers already
twice I should go see Suzanne and I was
not unhappy with my decision plus I had
another hour and a half to myself after
all the emotional stuff still lands does
it it does of course um the thing that I
realized was that endgame is the perfect
way to introduce mutants to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe do tell
according to the Hulk Smart Hulk the
energy of the Infinity stones is mostly
gamma gamma radiation that the Infinity
Gauntlet has been snapped three times on
earth releasing an ungodly amount of
gamma radiation like I wonder what
happens to jeans when they're exposed to
an ungodly amount of gamma radiation -
oh that's where we get mutants so I
think like if you if you wanted to bring
them in
that is that is as good a way as any to
be like oh [ __ ] remember the giant waves
of awful [ __ ] that's true because
there's been no mutants in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe yet or not even a
yeah I mean they kept on calling Scarlet
Witch and hey moved Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver they were like enhanced but
they're not mutants right like she was
given her powers through scientific both
of them were scientifically experiments
right also because I couldn't see the
word mutants right but in real Marvel
can and they were mutants right but I
guess you're right so they don't need to
even play the card of like hey they've
been here for the last 10 years nobody
said anything right they could literally
be like this happened since the [ __ ]
snap whoo that's smart yeah and it's
like that's how they're going to recast
everybody because those people weren't
mutants played by those people before so
you need an entirely new wave of people
who was like yeah no 14 years later
after in phase 5 you say oh yeah I was
born on such-and-such a day and on that
day then they trace it back and they're
like that was the day of the third snap
yeah
and everybody was born that day's
immunity what's your favorite part of
the movie fourth time
[ __ ] it's still the [ __ ] hammer
it's its cap holding the hammer like
it's still it's it's again the thing you
didn't know you wanted but once you get
it that that's that was my ultimate
disappointment with a game of Thrones
finale is that nothing happened that I
thought I wanted or nothing happened
that once I got it was like [ __ ] yeah
yeah that's better than I hoped
yeah like that's the night King that's
cooking than that King oh I didn't know
this was gonna happen
but oh [ __ ] thank you Arya for not being
a [ __ ]
alright wait so that we did and we done
talked about John wick I think so let's
talk about the news so hey it seems as
if we have a new Batman that's the news
that I wanted to get to you don't sing
we used to talk about Batman quite a bit
on this show but we don't do it that
much anymore but now we can because
they're about to make a new movie
they're about to make a new movie the
the scuttlebutt like the tail end of
last week was that Matt Reeves who's RIT
writing and directing the Batman is the
gentleman that gave us two of the the
plan of the movie correct - last planet
into the third with all three he didn't
do the first one right so he's making
the Batman and and and it suppose to be
gritty sort of more like he wants a
younger Bruce Wayne and so the two names
that were floated were Nicholas Hoult
who was beast in the the sort of post
x-men first class movies and was NOx was
that his name in fury road oh yeah yeah
wasn't he also about a boy he was about
a boy they were talking about about a
boy is about a bat Wow Wow
he's in that movie Tolkien right he's in
the movie Tolkien which he stole kid
just okay which I think five people saw
it's huge over name I don't know is it
really it's on the side of every bus
like Tolkien we got one yeah we know
this guy but yeah according to JC the
per screen average for Tolkien in the
States was like 50 bucks like we like
his books that's where it ends
yeah
we don't need to know his story we just
want the thing so yeah so was nicholas
hoult and and robert pattinson which it
sounds like it is Robert Pat it sounds
like it's Robert Pattinson
by all reports he's the guy that won the
role the internet either like lost its
collective mind or was like yeah all
right I see so same old same old same
old same old you know the internet doing
what the internet does um it'd be nice
if the Internet just wants surprised us
all by being like you know what good
yeah we like that yeah Rob Pattinson
makes sense moving on like of course
that was never gonna happen I you know
I'm all for it I think the dude's a good
actor like and a lot of people like [ __ ]
you Twilight vampires at Sparkle but hey
he acts in those movies but being more
importantly since those movies he's done
a lot of [ __ ] ton of act again he's in
this movie came out of can called the
lighthouse which is getting blown the
[ __ ] out of over there people [ __ ]
love it there's that Cronenberg movie
where he sits in the car the whole time
how's my Cosmopolis which like you know
sounds kind of goofy but if you can care
that's a one-man show more or less it he
carries that whole [ __ ] movie I think
he's a really good actor and I don't
know like you can't even use the
physical argument like whether or not
he's big enough to be Batman Michael
Keaton was Batman was like you know you
can put a sculpted suit on a guy in [ __ ]
and they're not wrong with likey Batman
either you know at the end of the day
but I'm curious I think it's I did not
turn me off in my in one iota and in
fact it probably made me more interested
I was a go yeah I mean it's one of those
like he did that thing where he got a
giant [ __ ] franchise - if you're
gonna be honest he's also an Harry
Potter
that's right like he got his [ __ ]
giant the thing that I never have to
work again if I don't want to thing yeah
and then decided to work again and made
really interesting choices yeah
like was that yeah I'm gonna go work
with directors that you know really
intrigue me I'm gonna do weird [ __ ]
offbeat movies just cuz they tickle me
because I don't give a [ __ ] if they make
any money cuz I don't need any money I
just want to go off and get better at
this thing that I want to do for the
rest of my life like why couldn't that
dude be good at Batman why couldn't like
the weird kind of mopey
on the exterior impression kind of
shallow pretty boy also be playing a
dude who on the exterior is kind of a
shallot pretty boy who's got deep
[ __ ] tortured soul inside and does
[ __ ] up stuff at night i buy that guy
as that guy cuz he's kind of that guy my
uh I think I'm Team Edward on this guy
I'm ready to see this happen I'm look
I'm ready for another Batman movie so
just cast somebody and get [ __ ] to it
man
like it's been too long at this point
yeah and we get that movie
June 25th 2021 are you [ __ ] me they
announced yeah 20 21 and we're 20 we're
not even June 2019 yeah that's two
[ __ ] years away piece is [ __ ] what do
they got planned for us between now and
then you got a Wonder Woman movie
happens between them yes
Joker no becoming right we'll get
Aquaman to by then you'll get birds of
prey
you'll get birds of prey there's enough
going on and the two rumored villains if
not more than two Clayface and hold on
who would I like to see [ __ ]
onomatopoeia but that's personal
Clayface and a classic
Batman villain that they've not done yet
who would be amazing they're doing black
masks in birds of prey right that's who
you and McGregor's playing man who said
man bad that's why I hired Nate man bad
zaz is good but I've done XY's right
like he was in one of the Dark Knight
movies one of the Nolan movies did they
do thousand Gotham as well has anybody
done man bat other than the cartoon that
was a great episode I wonder if their
fear of man bad is there like I don't
know that seems a little fake but it's
like the rest of it seems fake to like
just just by end although go the
distance
man-bat be kind of cool and Clayface be
amazing but those are two of the most
outlandish Batman villains and not
outlandish like I'm a clown who kills
people like that's kind of doable
right like that happened in the real
world with John Wayne Gacy but like you
never heard of like there's a guy who
turned himself into a giant [ __ ] bat
and [ __ ] and you never heard of like
there's a guy who like can morph into
other things like those are stretches so
I could see why they haven't touched
those yet who is it
the rumor is it's gonna be Catwoman and
penguin I mean like he's got such a rich
rogues gallery and they're like let's do
I don't know Joker penguin Catwoman
Joker penguin Catwoman over and over
again they just did [ __ ] penguin on
that Gotham show didn't they allegedly
apparently reportedly they did all of
them did they do Clayface and man-bat so
you picked I'm just saying we're onto
something here I mean that I mean look
I'm gonna say it I'm in but it's just
like [ __ ] Catwoman again we've seen a
few Catwoman and did they really think
that's the only like Batman villain that
mainstream America like cares about like
like all this is the Batman villain your
grandma knows like there's way more than
that and then what was the other one
penguin thing like they we've gotten the
Danny DeVito iteration now and the
burgess Meredith in the beginning and
now we've gotten the current rubbers
named Robin Lord tailors nothing
iteration seems like we're coming right
off of that I don't know i'm i would go
with villains that nobody's seen before
I mean the the one the one reason why
I'm not as unhappy about penguin thing
as you are is because it's been since
Danny DeVito since anybody seen one in a
movie right you know you have to know
yeah but the the great thing about
penguin and Catwoman to a lesser degree
is that he wires directly into who Bruce
Wayne is like every every great Batman
villain is a funhouse mirror version of
who Bruce Wayne is and so it's the Joker
is all about chaos and Batman is all
about order and you know mr. freeze is
all about [ __ ] science as is he
two-face is all about justice and
[ __ ] warped twisted justice and so is
he
penguin is all about a child of
privilege who decides which way to take
that privilege and who uses it the right
way and who uses the wrong way and he
was forgotten by the city and he's
remembered by the city and I think that
at the very least it becomes a story of
duality and becomes a story of the road
less taken or the or the the mirror
cracked and cracked badly no like that
you just made me like penguin a little
bit more where I'm like ooh that's good
man they're both rich boys both rich
boys who didn't you know weren't loved
by their parents one because their
parents were gone the other because he
was a monster yeah and whether that
monstrosity is physical or just
emotional you can still play both of
those and so they can both be [ __ ]
handsome Devils of Gotham City but one
of them is so scarred on the inside that
he can't see the pretty boy anymore
um where do you stand on like Tim Burton
II penguin with like I got flippers and
[ __ ] like that I I would rather not yeah
well yeah you really don't need that
especially in this day and age would be
a weird message to send yeah it's like
yeah I mean there's there's so many
different ways that you can get there
but you don't need [ __ ] doesn't even
need to be fat anymore I don't think so
right yeah like the Robin Lord Taylor
performance wasn't about being heavy
chef would be nice but but I think
there's a way to even play like body
dysmorphia like here's a person who grew
up and that is his his core insanity is
he does not see himself the way he
actually is in the world
ooh so if you look at the mirror and you
see the like [ __ ] the child that
nobody was ever happy with and the
manifestation of that is you're ugly
you're fat you're never good enough
you're never thin enough you're never
rich enough you're never enough to be
loved by the people who should love you
and that is the you that you grew up to
be like yeah I see myself as a giant
[ __ ] lard ass but I'm actually
Christian Bale which would be awesome
could you imagine he's like last time I
play Batman now I'm the penguin
[Laughter]
give me an Oscar
wow man [ __ ] that but so weight in
your version would he be like a thin
dude but when he looked in the mirror
it'd be like a heavy dude looking back
at him I think so
that's interesting but I bet you a lot
of people be like [ __ ] you like give me
the fat penguin that's what I grew up on
yeah again I'm sure you'll do a great
job with the material but [ __ ] man like
those guys again yeah or give me the
give me the mr. freeze give me the give
me the Victor freeze story
yeah because they've done it once but
like it was on yeah but like do the Paul
Dinis yeah like just reclaim that
character and make him tragic and
wonderful and awesome yeah and it's like
visually interesting you know the freeze
gun and all that [ __ ] and Christoph
Waltz could be him well done all right
so I'm in for this Batman movie but
apparently got a two-year [ __ ] wait
but we got a lot of things to see
between now and then how many Marvel
movies will happen in that time I don't
even [ __ ] know
like I don't remember what's on the
runway what do we got next up is
spider-man then after spider-man is
guardians 3 are you [ __ ] me
guardians is after spider-man and they
haven't even started guardians and he
ain't starting it till after wait where
the [ __ ] are all the Marvel movies yeah
Black Panther 2 will come if they even
started that they haven't started that
either yeah oh my god there's very few
things in the shoot man but they haven't
started those like they're not even
anywhere near production they haven't
even officially announced eternals yet
or the cast or anything so so is Marvel
slowing down for a year it sounds like
it Black Widow but they're not even
close to production on that either like
they're currently not in production on
any movie are they like there's
definitely the world in whoo yeah that's
right they're developing all the Disney
Plus shows but I mean post endgame and
post far from home which feels like it's
it'll be the Iron Man 3 to Avengers 2
yes like in game 1.5 yes it's actually a
good idea for them to [ __ ]
slow down a little bit like well let us
a reset our expectations for those
universes
let us want it a little bit more let us
not have had it for a little bit I can't
want it more than I do right now mark oh
my god you see how distressed I was when
I realized we're not getting three next
year I was like no no no that was my
face when I was like who won the
presidency like Oswald Cobblepot won the
president man oh man that's that's a
depressing thought I mean I guess they
got to stop and make some stuff but they
were on such a heavy clip of like two a
year
yeah you're done with that here's
another you're done with that here's
another well you know what you will get
before you get another big morale movie
another Saw movie yes
you know who's making us all it's got an
interesting pedigree Chris Rock is
making us all movies you know Chris
Rock's gonna toss saws salad and make it
brand new it feels as if it's like at
this point if you're a black comedian
you could make a horror movie which
which what you really feel is this
Jordan peel effect I think it's totally
the Jordan Peele effect he's not
directing though he's just coming up
with a story just kind of like rebooting
and producing whether he writes or not
but I think that idea of comedy and
horror being to a certain degree flip
sides of the same coin yeah cuz they're
all about precision and emotional
manipulation right like I'm gonna get
you to do a thing your body didn't
expect it to do which is either laugh or
jump I am no Jordan Peele but as a guy
who's made some comedy and then made
red-state and tusk I found that the
reaction buttons are very close to one
another if you can make somebody laugh
you can also unnerve them fairly easily
yes oh yeah I guess it makes sense you
know and so so I get it like if he's a
horror fan which it seems he is and he
wants to [ __ ] do it I get rolling the
dice in his Blum house so I was like
[ __ ] it roll the dice make a five
million dollar Saw movie his saw Blum
House movie was Lionsgate its Lionsgate
but James Blum is
singing James Wong James why not blunt
Blum's not bother get that wrong say why
would they let him in there it's
lionsgate they've made plenty of money
without him they don't need it he does
everything else but yeah so that's
coming October 23rd 2024 Chris man
[ __ ] that's it if I that portfolio
man and he's been directing quite a bit
lately he just did the Kenan Thompson
pilot oh yeah yeah good for him yeah
yeah get that money and also did that
like respect like people going oh he's
not just a comedian he could do all
these other things as well it's
important to be able to spend a bunch of
plates now if you could do one thing you
better do that one thing in this
insanely exceptional way that nobody
else can do a thing like that thing
because otherwise people are gonna be
like uh-huh what else can you do because
everyone multitasks now so it's smart
for him to be doing that they are
staffing up and casting up the Falcon
and Winter Soldier show so you're right
they are concentrating on the [ __ ] TV
shows and Kevin Feige he's heavily
involved in those shows
yeah it's through Marvel Studios not
Marvel TV so it's a foggy joint Wow
Daniel Bruhl is returning as Zemo really
yeah
what do you mean they count as emo in is
this a pre like what if he doesn't die
at the end of let him put that [ __ ]
mask on sure I mean look I was always
buying a subscription but that will make
me buy too
that's the only thing in civil war that
I like I did not didn't find fault with
it I was like I wish he'd put on that
mask yeah and I saw like a early concept
drawing of what the mask could look like
you know would've looked really dope so
if you have to bring him back they might
be able to mask him up they're bringing
him back in there bringing Emily VanCamp
as Sharon Carter back yeah and
apparently the rumor again it's the
Internet so who knows what they will
address and incorporate the fact that
now Anthony Mackie is playing Captain
America so this is a post snap
advantages the post snap adventure I'm
even more intrigued for some reason I
thought this is all pretty snap or
something yeah
so that means he'll be cap
yeah not Falcon not Falcon
so uh weren't they calling it still are
and I think there is also a world in
which they were calling it that before
endgame so as to not spoil it right but
for the time being it is still Falcon in
Winter Soldier Wow
did you lose your mind me what is it
weird
it's awesome I'm ready for that show I'm
ready for all those shows man it's a
good idea and especially if they're
letting the guy who did the movies like
if Kevin Feige is overseeing it oh
they're gonna tie in so well and [ __ ]
this is the dream like you know as much
as we all love those Marvel Netflix
shows clearly the Cinematic Universe was
like dare who Jessica what like they
didn't really acknowledge them so having
a show an ongoing series that is not
only acknowledged by the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but comes from the
minds of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
so it's tied in and [ __ ] that's that's
the dream it's fantastic although it's
still a little troubled by the fact that
there's no to Marvel movies next year
are we sure about that somebody want to
get online
spider-man is the last one for a minute
I think so
I mean the comments will tell us that we
were wrong I hope so maybe there's some
mean we are getting to see you're
[ __ ] [ __ ] your job is to look at the
news no some [ __ ] news
black dude we know there's black panther
and we know there's guardians coming but
they haven't started those and we know
there's a Captain Marvel to coming but
they haven't started still none of these
have been started right and we know
there's an as guardians of the galaxy
because that's totally what they're
gonna [ __ ] call that and guards is
doing got guns doing squad before he
even goes back I'm sorry I keep
retreading but and it's really alarming
to think that [ __ ] things are not
gonna be the way they were I hate
[ __ ] change mark what else we got I
think the last one will hit before we go
to Q&A is Hulu who you know
I've worked for them before on a Stephen
King show before they want to be in the
Stephen King business really badly so
they're making an eyes of the dragon TV
show did you ever read the eyes of the
Dragon
it is his game of Thrones basically it's
his high fantasy it's his like dragons
and wizards and sorcerers and Stephen
King is a [ __ ] wizard thing yeah
really I think I wrote it as a kind of
bedtime story for for one of his kids
and it was like yeah why don't you deal
with [ __ ] evil clowns and [ __ ]
Diamond Dogs like I'm gonna do fantasy
and the big bad guy is Randall Flagg who
is also the big bad guy in the stand and
is also the big bad guy are you [ __ ]
me
yeah Randall Flagg is the bad guy in
that world as well yeah have he's also
the bad guy in [ __ ] dark tower isn't
he and so this is part of his whole
giant [ __ ] country universe thing
that's [ __ ] dope I had no idea he
used him as much as that's his own devil
yeah that's cool he'd built his own
thing
yeah so that's that's currently
production I think Seth grahame-smith is
writing it the dude who did they employ
killer hunter
so yeah that's coming so in case you're
jonesing for Stephen King and more
connected universe Dark Tower
speaking of Zulu I saw as the dragon an
animation test on Howard the Duck yeah
looked really [ __ ] great like really
really amazing and like Dave Willis
who's the you know really the captain of
our ship he come from Aqua Teen Hunger
Force he created that show he had
written like a little bit for them to do
for the animation test because you go
out to a bunch of different houses and
you're like here man do what you can for
this like two minutes and it was a quack
foo sequence and it was [ __ ]
fantastic
so that's moving along at a at a slow
pace but a pace nonetheless
I mean animation is slow anyway credibly
unless it's South Park in which like
they're doing it every week yeah but
everything else takes forever but yeah
that's so far so good looking good there
like hence the announcement of Rick and
Morty season four
oh so exciting I know but not until
November November November but I believe
they've been working on it for like two
years already yeah well one of those
years was just negotiations though right
remember for a minute yeah that's right
I had to figure out whether they were
coming back and then they made that huge
[ __ ] deal and so it made sense that
they're like they're coming yeah I can't
wait man that'll make up for the lack of
Marvel movies next years we'll have some
more Rick and Morty
I just need distractions mark just keep
me [ __ ] full with distractions is
that all the news
mattes all the news give it up for Mark
you read you the news all right folks
now we come in time to show that is the
queue a part of the show man as where
you the audience gets involved you
provide the content for us to talk about
we have three set surprises here and
they're all the same prize but there's
three sets of them you're gonna win if
you ask a question and we like that
question you're gonna win tickets to
tickets to 40x
theatrical experience the 4dx theater is
right here in downtown where it's down
to LA live at LA live if you've never
seen a movie in 40 X and the 40 X
tickets come courtesy of our good friend
Brad deacon if you've never seen a 40 X
film oh my god the chair vibrates until
you come all over the place that's they
won't put that on the ticket but that's
how I see it it is a fantastic
experience and boy oh boy I said to
somebody man you should go see [ __ ]
Avengers in gaming than these chairs and
somebody came back like I did and they
just talked a lot in that movie so their
chair didn't do a lot of this [ __ ] what
not notice me I did and I can't walk
anymore yes it's a great experience man
and so if you ask question we like it
we're gonna give you two tickets to a 40
X movie and you're gonna win this
sweet-ass signed by me and Mark print
done by 1/8 king of the podcasters
featuring yours truly as Godzilla of
sorts and Mark screaming as he always
does
encounter one alright so JC who is the
owner under style of this here
establishment
he's got the microphone in his hands
he's gonna pick three people and we're
gonna dive into the Q&A so JC pick away
well you didn't even try
literally pointed to the guy in front
what's your name sir hey guys I'm
Enrique Enrique I'm gonna give it up for
Enrique how are you sir how adorable you
plotted yourself okay so here's a little
conspiratorial question why is it that
the latest Marvel villains meaning kill
monger and tennis because nobody really
gives a [ __ ] about Thor sister and
vibrating lady vibrating lady format man
in the walls yeah yeah I believe that's
what her action figure says vibrating
lady yeah she's very popular for a
certain segment of the population
exactly what way is it that kill monger
antennas make so much social and
political sense the bill is right I
think that maybe given that Disney are
becoming a little bit our content and
communication overlords right yes and we
should give Internet why is it that both
tannaz and kill monger makes so much
sense
as the villains are they trying to quell
our environmental and racial unrest as
mass culture producers is that the end
of the question that's the end okay
waiting for it are they are they trying
to quell racial unrest was that it or
foment kill monger like Disney as mass
producers of culture yes I trying to
quell environmental arrest via tennis
and racial unrest via kill monger I I
don't think that comes from Disney I
don't think there's a brain trust that
goes hey man we have an agenda say these
things I like having been around it and
on the inside on the outside it just
don't work like that like if if you're
looking for somebody to be like hey
who's responsible for this
in that case always Kevin Feige right
and I think it's not pushing some agenda
or anything they're just trying to make
a compelling character like rather than
just you know you dismissed vibrating
lady because she doesn't really have a
compelling story right like so she's
easily dismissed it compared to a fan
owes or kill monger who have rich
vibrant [ __ ] villain backstories and
stuff that make them almost questionable
as to whether or not you know they're
villains from a certain perspective
you're like oh that kind of makes sense
except for the genocide thing you know
so I think that's just a product of
let's make interesting characters I
don't think they're like you know let's
let's use these movies for a greater
purpose
the only greater purpose they're trying
to get to is your [ __ ] wallet over
and over again so that's my take on it
but you but interesting like what a
great [ __ ] annoyed but wonderful
thought you
I think that if Disney was trying to
quell racial unrest they would not have
had a character say throw me in the sea
like my ancestors before me they knew
that death was better than bondage they
would not and have us believe that they
would not even choose to invoke this
entire line of thinking which is oh [ __ ]
colonizers are the worst which is
ultimately what that movie is kind of
about which is like kind of a little bit
of if you left your own devices I'm not
[ __ ] with mercilessly you can be
amazing and have lovely technology and
all that [ __ ]
and also you need to open up your
borders and help people if you can help
people that's the ultimate message but
kill manga is all about like oh [ __ ] you
know who [ __ ] us up white people you
know how to fix that lots of black
people with guns which doesn't sound
like seem to be doesn't sound like
something that Bob Iger is like can you
put that on a movie yeah you know I
think that'd be good for our
shareholders right like the thing that's
interesting is that a Disney movie
actually said [ __ ] like that yeah you
know it's they they found an artist that
they trusted and they let that artist
tell the story he wanted to tell and if
part of that story might make certain
segments of the population uncomfortable
so be it but I don't believe that there
was a mandate and I think also part of
the reason I think they're letting their
filmmakers bite the hand a lot more
lately too because they realize like the
culture allows it like they realize how
[ __ ] big they are that like there's
some gigantic I'm not gonna say monopoly
but you're you know they are fast taking
over every piece of media you know in in
the world and stuff so I you know what
was I going with that it was just a
really sighing point that I just knows
oh there there clearly okay with people
like doing [ __ ] that you would think is
counterproductive to Disney culture pick
case in point I didn't see it but every
review I read of Dumbo was like this
movie makes fun of [ __ ] Disney like
right - it's [ __ ] face and [ __ ] so I
don't think anyone I don't I'm not
saying nobody's mind in the store but I
they care as long as like the content
isn't like this is a movie in praise of
Hitler like okay I didn't mean it to be
like there are these guys behind like oh
there are this environmentalist so we're
gonna make the bad guy the one that's
thinking about the environment so let's
[ __ ] kill them up with all the
arrangers behind it right but maybe
there's a little bit of the zeitgeist
and I don't mean to get a little bit of
political no but the lego movie made the
bad guy Lord business or war was his
name right the lego movie the lego movie
yes so I think this started a bit of
this I guess flowing around I mean and
it's it's one of those things where
especially like ant-man versus the wasp
and like vibrating lady like that's a
small movie with like a personal story
what was their name ghost ghost oh yeah
yeah like it's just way easier to say
than vibrating lady but that's far more
evocative yeah that's fun and I
instantly knew who you were talking
about I was like wasp right well yeah
excuse me and so because that story is
small the villains plan needs to be
intimate it needs to be personal whereas
like what Conda is all about the taking
your place in the world stage and
fantasies about
galactic [ __ ] oppression and
environmentalism and like the lego movie
it's like Lord business is a child's
idea of who their dad is and it was all
about how I can't get love from my daddy
doesn't let me play with his toys like
it it reduces down to an inherently
personal story that that feels like it's
saying a large thing and it is about
sort of their rights of the individual
and what it feels to not be a number and
to find your special place in the world
while also occasionally yet it is about
how no one is special because everyone's
special right wait isn't that what the
Incredibles is about yeah that was like
the plan of the villain right once
everyone's super then no one will be
I don't know I think it's fairly common
at least in the last 20 years maybe even
longer than that for like big
entertainment companies to take shots at
themselves by way the movies go out it's
a safe position to do it from right like
you could be like yeah [ __ ] rich people
why you're a rich person like that's
kind of yeah tried and true in this
business I mean does Disney is way
tighter about like a Mickey Mouse like
Mickey Mouse is never gonna be like you
know who we should kill all the [ __ ]
ducks
Donald's like why because I don't wear
pants
yes Donald you know like they're they're
way more like protective of some of that
core IP that belongs to them but when it
comes down to like the [ __ ] Marvel's
and what comes down to like Pirates of
the Caribbean even to a certain degree
which gets to talk about occasionally
things like you know race and class and
gender and and all that stuff they have
a little bit more leeway because they
realize a little more distance between
the brand and the product well yeah like
Disney bland is never gonna have like
these down with whitey day
my guess I mean black we have the two is
coming so like if you have to have a day
at Disney for Black Manta to take us
into the culture mark does anybody have
it down with whitey day because I might
like to attend what's all this about
where am i you supposed to go go down to
that was a great [ __ ] question
thought-provoking and and got great
answers out of me and Mark give it up
for me one
well done every go English not the first
language either is it [ __ ] well done
man
could you imagine going to another
country and [ __ ] drop and look up in
the word quell no I got this
Quinn not just quell but quell in
another language
totally like twice like that's the word
he stuck with pretty amazing huh you got
a high bar what's your name my name is
Grayson Grayson yeah shut up
[ __ ] a man give it up for dick ladies
a job [ __ ] man that would've been a
great Kevin Grayson would have been a
great name to grow up with [ __ ]
Grayson Smith back to grace man or just
a flat grace Smith was my mother that's
her name great grace Oh close anyone
back to you so Grayson how are you I am
great is actually my birthday so man 26
26 26 ah [ __ ] man Warner Brothers used
to own this but nobody owns it now so
this is [ __ ] sing the song one two
three
ooh happy birthday to you happy birthday
dear racer take a Robin happy birthday
thank you what can we do you for
so my question is so since we're seen
like this really awesome era of compact
movies and I'm coming to 90s and are
nurses more into video games so do you
ever think we'll see a renaissance and
this pop culture phenomenon with video
game adaptations because lately have you
seen we have had failures constantly
we're on the right track right now or I
didn't detect the Pikachu do kind of
well and yeah I haven't seen it but my
kid [ __ ] loved it yeah yeah do you
see him no only only because Pikachu was
not my generation I agree III picked
Pikachu's a cute character and [ __ ] and
I like Ryan Reynolds I'm happy to watch
it when it hits like iTunes but that was
never something that was gonna grab me
because that was something that was a
90s kid kind of thing yeah it feels like
video game movies especially of that are
buoyed and fueled by nostalgia right
like you have to be born of that age to
have played that game for it to have
meant a thing to you when you were nine
and so 20 years later like oh [ __ ]
finally they did sonic exactly the way I
hope they were gonna do sonic creepy
yeah
oh that mouth ah but I also think there
is something especially for older video
games that does not translate as well to
movies because this the the engine of
your enjoyment is not you're telling me
a story right it's I'm telling me a
story using these things and so trying
to codify what had been your experience
into an experience there tends to be a
gulf there there are there are games
like like Last of Us which is all about
story and it's telling you a story that
could be a movie that every four minutes
you got to kill something but like
there's a narrative that drives you
through it that I think to adapt
something like that makes sense and I
also think you need to remember why
people loved playing your game like the
Assassin's Creed movie was like hey you
know people love about this [ __ ] not
killing people in the Renaissance but
[ __ ] future intrigue
and animus like who gives a [ __ ] if you
play that game you want it to be jumping
from rooftops killing [ __ ] in
like Constantinople like that's only
reason I care like when I play the games
it's cut team cut scene cut scene ooh
murder you know like make that but like
remember why people love the game and
try and give them that experience as
much as you can but it's it is a dodgy
thing to do because the the the the tiny
hole that you have to navigate to please
people who are coming to it from
nostalgia people who know nothing about
it at all people who own the [ __ ] IP
who decided like now we gotta have gold
coins in here like really yeah you got
to have [ __ ] gold coins why it's
gameplay it's not enjoyment so yeah it's
it's it's possible but it requires a lot
of patience and a lot of like hard
thinking about why anybody would want to
go see a movie beyond I recognise the
title I think like anything in the right
hands couldn't be turned into something
[ __ ] wonderful as we've seen with
like even comic book characters like
[ __ ] when they announced guardians the
galaxy I remember being like what like
really all those characters you're gonna
pick that you can't turn that into
something good and they turn it into
something great so I imagine there's
somebody out there that can make a great
video game movie you know what I'm
saying cuz it's always the same
complaint you hear over and over it's
like how do you turn that into a story
you are playing the game it's not really
a story but I think in the right hands
somebody could pop it I just don't I
don't know that there's been something
that an IP that you know has lent itself
to mainstream storytelling in the way
that would connect with the three-act
structure like that a movie going
audience looks for you know I'm saying
like certainly there's no pac-man movie
but there should be able to be you know
yeah like that's the most obvious one
Legend of Zelda like how do you not
[ __ ] turn that into a movie or a
trilogy bunny it's like that's just an
adventure right you know and I think
that that even for me one of the ones
that I love them
seeing it today it's god-awful but
MORTAL KOMBAT right because the game
entirely is just people punching each
other but if you decide that it's into
the dragon then done like I found a
model I can overlay on top of it where
it's we're going into an island there's
a martial arts competition and we're
just all these characters going to punch
each other in the face for a couple of
hours until your hero gets the
redemption he needs you're probably
going to pick the wrong hero because
it's got to be Johnny Cage and it gives
a [ __ ]
but like at least it feels as if I know
what this can be I'm gonna put it on top
of that and the character still get to
do all we needed to do you know they
they they're forced to fight so it's
like a secret Wars kind of yeah and
they're forced to kill each other and
that's why it's like finish I want to
see your movie like that's so good amen
see that could be like handle than
[ __ ] totally if all if you're only
nostalgic there's so little to the game
that you can do whatever you want with
it or it's the it's Zelda it's I'm gonna
give you Lord of the Rings but just
[ __ ] with link instead of Frodo and
just like do that and while I haven't
seen it like it does seem like good use
of the of the you know the Pokemon IP to
like take those characters and make a
movie that's not like it's just like the
[ __ ] game from what I understand it
it's nothing like the [ __ ] game right
I would prefer them they just take the
world of we know like if they made alas
dose maybe it would be uncomfortable to
see someone play with Joel cuz Troy
Baker stole to me and I think no one
should ever played Troy
alright Joel right so I think they
should disease like the universe of the
games like Warcraft kind of got it but
again it was not good it's pretty bad
like I think just the world and like
what other kids are doing in that will
be more interesting to me and like them
survive and if it was the Last of Us
because again it's literally it's just
[ __ ] Indiana Jones with like a lady
and two guns and like if you can just
tell me a good adventure story and drop
a Lara Croft into it that's kind of all
I need just make me enjoy it and there
is so little of that IP that's required
beyond she's got two guns right yeah
maybe she gets a boner once right
yeah bare midriff done
what would you do if somebody was like
we're gonna give you two million bucks
to write a video game movie your choice
any video game but you have to come up
with it right now do you have two
million dollars in your pocket you just
went to the bank if I have to if I pick
a game to write a movie about right now
Dig Dug who said that [ __ ] a man
that'd be an interesting story to tell
his [ __ ] gotta go underground
and pump up things with air so they blow
up okay likewise I'll shoot him it's
like because Dig Dug
is a bunch of [ __ ] kids trapped
underwater and [ __ ] Thailand and some
like spelunking accident gone awry and
who's got a [ __ ] get him out the best
digger in the world his name is Doug
what does he do
Doug Diggs die it's the [ __ ] like
Teasley presents Dig Dug a heartbreaking
tale of true life rescue and and bravery
where's my two men who can we get to do
this my name's Doug I got you I was just
gonna say pitfall but I like that way
more that was a great question and it
yielded great responses give it up for
me WOD what it like what have you got
like kathryn bigelow to do a Metroid
movie what was the plot again it's each
other adventure it's like a space
adventure where you have to kill the big
mother brain but you as a kid when you
played Metroid you were this lace face
and [ __ ] that man you know what game we
can [ __ ] make a movie of it's wrong
[Laughter]
yeah you're right almost any [ __ ]
well-spaced case so the big reveal in
1986 was when you win the game you take
your helmet off and it's a lady that
you've been playing with so all the
little boys were like what why I'm a
girl but it would be perfect for 2019
well done also last thing today is the
39th anniversary of Empire Strikes Back
release if we do mention that today here
we are at scum and villainy Cantina on
the 39th anniversary of the release of
the day came out yeah trying to think if
I saw it opening day I mean my world
wasn't engineered like that back then
because my old man brought me to the
movie so I would go when he was free and
like there was no like it's Friday the
movie came out that happened later like
in preteens when I started hanging out
with friends and going in the movies
like every [ __ ] weekend and then
sometimes we just went and like like I
remember once we were there's like we're
five 11 year olds and we went to see
Gandhi
three [ __ ] hours man and and I was
the one that called for it I was like we
should see Gandhi and the other [ __ ]
horse cats were looking at me gone like
why I was like no hold on it's about to
get good it's like a mummy move he's got
sand powers hold on he's gonna get
hungry hold on yeah man that's [ __ ]
crazy
so anyway if I did indeed go on day one
which I may have because I remember
dragging my parents to like what did
they call it when they were you ran
movies back in the day
Oh extended engagement second run thank
you and they would do second run not
like you know $2 house or a dollar a
second run meaning like a year later
they brought Star Wars back out and show
and so when they had the trailer for The
Empire Strikes Back in the very first
one they rereleased Star Wars and put
that trailer on instead and I convinced
it was just something that like they
would do a lot later on the like in the
future now they don't do it at all
because you just watch trailers online
but was the movie what was the what was
the movie we all went to see cuz it had
it was it the Star Wars trailer it was
Wing Commander yes had the the Phantom
Menace yes a fan I paid cash money for
lucky I went to Times Square like I
dodged [ __ ] porn theaters to go in
like a week job like it would it was
water boy meet Joe Black was the teaser
and the Wing Commander was the the frame
commander was like had the number seven
grossed that week yes because like who
the [ __ ] knew Wing Commander nope
everybody went there for five minutes is
the Star Wars effect that was also when
they rereleased Star Wars in 78 or 79
when they added the a new hope' title to
it was the 79 really yeah the 77 didn't
it just said stars
wow I didn't I didn't know a little bit
of [ __ ] trivia there give it up for
JC man well done
well if I did go out and it went on day
one then 39 years ago in the timestream
I'm sitting in a movie theater with my
mom and dad and having my mind [ __ ]
shredded like that was you know I was I
came in for Star Wars too and they gave
me something so much [ __ ] better and
I thought I liked Star Wars but after
Empire was like [ __ ] Star Wars like this
is the [ __ ] universe oh I love that
movie so much even as a [ __ ] kid I
was just like this is class like this is
[ __ ] this was better than the other
one and [ __ ]
what about you do you go see it it would
not have been first-run no like I don't
think I could have amassed the parental
initiative to do that like well it's not
going anywhere
let's go see in [ __ ] August that yes
that was the feeling bag man it wasn't
even like oh we'll go next week it's
just like well yeah it was like a summer
vacation and it rained wherever we were
it was like oh [ __ ] all right let's go
to the movies
what's it he likes the [ __ ] space
pictures let's just go and see this one
and then we end up seeing it three
months late and yeah it's the movie that
teaches a generation about tragedy right
like oh [ __ ] it doesn't have to end well
your hero can lose oh [ __ ] I learned
that [ __ ] on the Bad News Bears man it
was the Bad News Bears of Star Wars
movies where they lost at the end yeah
it was so [ __ ] eye opening and
wonderful and and and also like I
remember like it was something that I
could bond with my parents over because
even they were kind of like he's his
father you know like they weren't
steeped in Star Wars but knew enough
about it and you know that's a story
that even if you're not deep into it
they you know it's all presented right
there in that movie so I remember the
whole ride home them talking about that
with me and enjoying that I was so
[ __ ] engaged like they they saw their
son come to life
in regards to this [ __ ] so they fed into
it by being like oh did you know that
was his dad it was like [ __ ] no nobody
did you idiots like that's it's one of
the greatest cinematic secrets of Altima
shut up turn around Drive that's when I
sit back here and think about what I saw
39 years [ __ ] man wonder what they're
gonna do for the 40th big party store
celebration in Anaheim is that right
that's a big party it is yeah and I
think last week was the 20th anniversary
of Phantom Menace yeah 19 20th
anniversary of that happen we didn't get
as much gas out of that one did we
well I got power holy [ __ ] let's do 20
minutes Phantom Menace that happened as
well I mean I do think that that
vampires the movie that teaches
generation about sort of trauma and
tragedy than Phantom Menace is the one
that teaches a generation about
disappointment like oh I waited my whole
life for this
it taught one generation disappointment
but another generation it taught like
hey man this is your snow and go for it
may seem to dig it their kids out there
still love jaar jaar go figure
I do feel like I before a rise of
Skywalker comes out I sort of owe myself
one big rewatch and everything like soup
to nuts I'm hoping there's some theater
I'm hoping Disney allows somebody to do
this was for a long time they were super
[ __ ] tight by releasing those movies
in theaters so I'm hoping that by this
time they like you know what let's do a
[ __ ] marathon it pains me to say
let's go to the El Capitan for like 20
hours and watch Star Wars do the saga do
the saga soup-to-nuts I'll do that with
you I'll buy the popcorn my knee still
doesn't work right from [ __ ] that
first Avengers marathon in 32 hours in
the all-caps seats I'd be all for though
now I wouldn't do it at the outcast this
is suck do you know the worst I know
they're really uncomfortable but like I
would go to like one of those lay back
chair theaters and [ __ ] I would do 20
hours of Star Wars there's a there's a
dining fee
in Marina del Rey yes yes there is yeah
there is
I did I did The Hobbit Marathon they're
the only new could you keep eating the
whole time yeah it'd be like watching a
movie at home it'd be like living in the
Wally future we've always wanted cupcake
through a straw please alright last
question let's pick up JC
what's your name sir a team what is a
team a team give it up for team ladies
and gentlemen welcome sir thank you
what's on the shirt we can Tina merch
yeah is that here you guys made those
[ __ ] sweet sidenote and this is a
reference to and so this is a reference
to episode well a podcast you guys well
I listened to you guys a lot so I'm
gonna reference something that you
mentioned a while back true story
earlier today me and my girlfriend are
walking down the alley walking down the
street here and I saw the alley to this
building and I said thought to myself
and said out loud oh that's where Kevin
and marks talked about blowing each
other and and you're like let's see if
it's talked
so yeah I just I see one guy in a
baseball hat and uh hats bobbin and the
other guy sure is smiling a lot my
question so I always I'm a big I've
always well Batman movies but for the
most part I've been pretty good and I'm
a big Bane fan mm-hmm and I always felt
like he hasn't been done right even
though it's been twice his last
iteration was pretty good the one on
Gotham no no ohh was the one of God and
Sid how was the Gotham iteration wait
he's in Gotham bad really all right so
we're talking about so what was the
other oh the other one was in Batman and
Robin Rises Dark Knight Rises Dark
Knight right well that was one but what
was the other we don't acknowledge that
one that one right yeah with poison ivy
that's right so if if if DC ever got
their [ __ ] together I've always wanted
to see I'm a big fan of the Knights
trilogy going back to the comic books
night Nino night nightfall night quest
nights end yeah so if they were to make
a movie based on that I know it'd be
pretty long and Batman would have to be
established focusing on that that that
trilogy who would be like who would be
your choice to be Bane Azrael or mainly
Bane Azrael in like how many movies do
you think that would be cuz that's a
long series you know what to do I mean
well I think you get three right like
they won't give you any more than that
right you get your trilogy and it's set
up for that because there's like three
chapters they just got to compress yeah
so much into each movie but also I'm
bringing up Bane because I remember he
was teased for the longest time before
he actually showed up and started
kicking ass and it made me think about
how Marvel the MCU teased panels you
know for six years and so I was like
okay if you're a focus not just on a
collaboration of different characters
but focus on one character and bring in
a comic book villain tease but make it
last for a long series like how would
you do it mmm
well Bane if we're doing real band he's
got to be Latin correct yes III go
Javier Bardem oh oh my god that was on
me what a good [ __ ] call holy [ __ ]
he'd be good and we seen him do a
version of him that one Bond movie where
he had no job remember he took his jaw
out and share no that was creepy yeah
he'd be [ __ ] good I think I think I
bet he'd be like I played that character
before I don't need then he shoots you
in the head with that cattle prod thing
free Bitcoin [ __ ] call [ __ ] that was
good I can't beat that I was gonna say
Antonio Banderas [ __ ] that was good
Javier Bardem Pedro Pascal I'm Sega
Pedro Pascal Pedro Pascal the
mandalorian ventures I mean that dude
occurs to me is incredibly in shape but
not like yea ripped and [ __ ] like that
but a harvey Bardem seems like the
contactor there's like i put on a
hundred pounds of muscle weight mouth
you know [ __ ] go method and crazy oh
god that's a good idea I think I go army
hammer for uh for Ezreal my taking am I
taking all of it for that is [ __ ]
fantastic man cuz he looks like a
[ __ ] angel that army hammered [ __ ]
but he acts like the devil
and that's what that character has to
devolve into Madison she could [ __ ]
tall man - really great poles and what
was the last one we need
I guess who would be Batman it would be
Batman because it's three movies it's
it's nightfall night fall night quest
and night seven nights in nights end is
when he comes back and chip yeah so
you've got an interesting trilogy where
like Bruce Wayne isn't even gonna be
part of Part two right technically maybe
they cut to him in the bed going oh
SciQuest i didn't lecture his comics but
he did that side thing in the South
America or that's interesting is he as
real Batman killing people and going
crazy because he's got a mad queen or
Mad King storyline and so that's good I
hadn't thought about that man they
should [ __ ] do that all right but
who's Batman here's back with all due
respect to Robert Pattinson who is going
to be Batman but in this version of
Batman and you have to have an older
Batman who's been Batman for quite some
time so you can have a young Batman you
know I always say Jon Hamm like even
when I come I am Jon Hamm so I was Jon
Hamm this time who could be an older you
know I think I've said it once before on
the show so it's not a very original
idea but I think I think you give
Clooney another bite of it man and not
like the you know the Joel Schumacher
version like the [ __ ] like here's the
actor actor version like you know go
crazy I'm think he'd be a good old
Batman not a good old Batman but a good
old Batman you could bring back a flick
a flick as well but he just did it right
and he clearly don't want to do it no
more but who do you think you look let's
go to you you've got to [ __ ] amazing
pose you're gonna say something like
Jesus I'm gonna drop the mic back Jesus
you're right
you can't kill army hammer because you
very alright I'm gonna give you two I'm
gonna give you the one that they
probably do and then one that they won't
do but I think they should I hold on
wait I'm gonna find out which one I want
more okay
oh I want to hear your version first and
then let me down gently after with their
version I've been watching Star Trek
discovery the second season Anson mount
has as Captain Pike has been doing
[ __ ] amazing work Louis he was he was
Black Bolt who never [ __ ] sick oh
yeah he was on that [ __ ] Canadian
western show though yeah AMC yeah like a
train hell on wheels hell on wheels he's
good at yeah he was blackballed and
that's great in Star Trek discovery and
he's like he's old enough he's got the
song pepper hair he's got some miles on
him like oh you could you you can play
him a little bit younger without doing
too much and then he's salt and pepper
Bruce Wayne later if they're making this
the one that they do choose is Brad Pitt
and I think that thanks to the magic
[ __ ] Marvel technology you could
young Fi Brad Pitt or even [ __ ]
Gemini magic do you see the dear minor
man trailer yeah where it's like young
Will Smith and old will and it's like
that's [ __ ] young Will Smith well
it's more old Will Smith and then a
cartoon of young Will Smith right like
what I looked at it like I was like I
don't get it what's and I'm like oh he's
meant to be him not a early CG version
of him writing like that so it's meant
to be a younger version of him so I've
been in quite nail it like Marvel's
nailed it right but it's all I am I
alone in that as everyone reacted well
to that they reacted way better than and
Will Smith as the genie
I look I think the movie looks good but
I just like it looked to me like CG yeah
whereas those martyr like when they did
Robert Downey jr. and they did Michelle
Pfeiffer that looked like that was for
real they can make it at this point do
an entire movie
that and all right isn't that what
Martin Scorsese is doing with the
Irishman or something like he's D ageing
everybody in it
yeah and they did a whole movie where
they D aged Sam Jax yeah they could pull
that off me Sam chuckles easier because
a cuz Jack don't crack just jack yeah
like enough markers are there that you
only got to fudge ten years to make him
look yeah I go Brad Pitt and I think
like old Brad Pitt like post broken-bat
Brad Pitt like he's still one of the
finest [ __ ] actors of his generation
is actually it's weird when he said I
had never thought about that before but
I'm like I would actually like to see
Brad Pitt [ __ ] do Bruce Wayne and
should he need a lot I know that much
cuz that's Brad Pitt's like go to acting
thing just sits there and eat french
fries I know Alfred he's crazy he's
crazy
I liked your casting way better than
mine I was per usual and [ __ ] did you
give us a Batman yet yeah I did I went
to Japan another but the years was even
better than [ __ ] but more importantly i
but you just made me go like who i would
like to see that that is a possible
go-to for them in the future I mean
Nolan you know bit a little bit for Dark
Knight Rises in as much as like hey
there's Bane breaking back Batman's back
but I you know I think they could they
could withstand to do that again maybe
within the maybe 10 years from now
because then they're far enough away
from like Nolan's vein that somebody
could give it a shot but then Javier
Bardem will be like 86 he will be an
elderly gentleman god it's good work you
still have old Bane you don't need like
[ __ ] did you see Arnold
Schwarzenegger attempt to get knocked
down by a by a do you didn't [ __ ]
Brazil or whatever and he how old is
that man 71 years old
71 in front of drugs off a dude with a
surprised dropkick it was incredible
like our 71 year old arms Flores Negras
standing in public somewhere kid comes
out of nowhere
looking's drop cases and he goes and
then goes back to his conversation yeah
yes it was pretty [ __ ] pretty amazing
all right yes that sounds fine that's a
great question Q it's a great answer it
deserves a great price give it up he
wanted ladies a brother oh my god
everything's been signed our prize has
been given out the news is done I mean
the tank is empty and the show is at an
end have you had a good time ladies and
gentlemen I can't thank you enough for
being here but let's be honest there is
no show without the guys sitting there
there's my left who finds the news for
us and has all the best ideas give it up
for mr. mark barnard and ladies and
gentlemen and that is fat man be on for
this week I'm Kevin Smith I am up renard
and next week same fat time same bat
Channel SModcast calm or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith night everybody
[Applause]
you
[Music]
you